le modem c'est le mouvement démocrate
c'est un parti politique fondé en 2007
par françois bayrou et nous les
démocrates
nous croyons en la force de ce grand
courant ce grand courant démocrate qui
irriguent avec constance la vie
politique française on nous a longtemps
catalogué comme des modérés pas tout à
fait à droite pas tout à fait à gauche
un peu indécis comme un filet d'eau
tiède ou un centre mou mais nous disons
au contraire que le projet que nous
portons est radicalement différent de
celui des autres familles de pensée de
la vie politique française
notre vision de l'homme c'est celle d'un
être de raison un être de conscience à
l'aide de relations aux autres qui va
par l'exercice de sa responsabilité de
sa liberté accéder à l'émancipation et
nous pensons que l'émancipation c'est la
finalité de toute action publique
alors à une gauche prisonnière de la
tradition marxiste qui se donne comme
seul horizon
l'égalisation des conditions matérielles
nous disons que les aspirations humaines
sont en fait beaucoup plus complexes
qu'elles sont multiples et que l'on doit
tenir compte de cette multiplicité pour
concevoir de bonne politique et puis à
une droite qui s'est construite par
accumulation de sédiments bonapartiste
néoconservateurs néolibéraux et qui est
bien à la peine d'ailleurs aujourd'hui à
définir son identité
nous disons que la vitalité démocratique
repose sur la qualité des liens que les
citoyens tissent entre eux au sein de
communautés vivantes et que le pouvoir
doit être déconcentré qui doit être
répartie qui doit être partagé et qu'on
doit l'installer là où il peut être
exercée avec justice et efficacité
que ce soit au niveau très local dans
les collectivités où que ce soit au
niveau européen et cet autre solution a
été défendue avec ardeur par une longue
chaîne d' esprit visionnaire convaincu
qu entre la droite et la gauche une
autre voie est possible
un autre projet de société le projet
démocrate alors vous allez me dire tout
ça ce sont des mots c'est pas très
concret mais il suffit de se retourner
sur notre histoire quelques instants
pour s'apercevoir de l'ampleur des
avancées et des conquêtes que ce courant
à portez à notre pays on peut citer par
exemple la politique familiale li vg les
apl la liberté de l'enseignement la
construction européenne la moralisation
de la vie politique le salaire minimum
l'intéressement et la participation
toutes ces réalisations ce sont les
nôtres et elle témoigne de ce que ce
grand courant a apporté à la france
et puis on peut aussi se retourner sur
les quatre années qui viennent de
s'écouler sur le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macron pour s'apercevoir qu'avec lui
avec nos ministres avec nos
parlementaires avec nos partenaires de
la république en marche nous avons
réalisé nous avons concrétisé un certain
nombre d'engagements qui étaient les
nôtres depuis longtemps je m'explique le
premier texte la première loi que nous
avons voté en 2017 c'est la loi sur la
moralisation de la vie politique portée
par françois bayrou et qui répond à un
engagement constant de la famille
démocrate
dans la foulée nous avons réformé
l'apprentissage nous avons dédoubler les
classes dans les réseaux d'éducation
prioritaire et nous avons donné la
priorité à l'école primaire l'année
dernière emmanuel macron a fait faire à
la construction européenne un grand pas
en avant avec un budget commun et une
dette commune des états membres de
l'union européenne on pourrait aussi
citer la participation citoyenne dont
marc fesneau vice président du modem et
le ministre on pourrait citer aussi le
nouvel acte de décentralisation du
pouvoir vers les collectivités locales
qui est porté par jacqueline gourault
toutes ces réalisations jusqu'en 2017
elles étaient des rêves elles étaient
nos espérances et bien sous ce
quinquennat elles seront devenus réalité
alors évidemment nous pensions que notre
projet ne s'arrête pas là qu'il est en
quelque sorte inachevé et qu'il y a
encore beaucoup à faire pour construire
un monde plus juste et c'est pourquoi
nous allons continuer à nous battre pour
un renouveau démocratique qui
garantissent le pluralisme c'est à dire
le respect de toutes les opinions pour
une europe plus démocratique
une europe qui soit rendu aux citoyens
et une europe qui met sa puissance au
service de la paix de la sécurité du
développement partout dans le monde nous
plaidons pour une écologie humaniste et
un modèle de développement qui donne sa
chance à chacun et puis nous défendrons
toujours les solidaires tu es à tous les
âges de la vie avec le soutien aux
familles avec la modernisation de notre
système de retraite avec la question du
grand âge et de l'autonomie et pour que
ces idées là pour que ses priorités pour
que nos idées restent au pouvoir en 2022
et bien le moment est sans doute venu de
rassembler les forces démocrates et
d'unifier ce grand courant de la vie
politique française car ce qui nous
rassemble est beaucoup plus grand que ce
qui nous divise et ce qui nous rassemble
ce sont nos idées et le projet de
société que nous voulons porter pour la
france